Have you ever noticed that the most
intolerant people on the planet are the
people who claim to be the champions of
tolerance? Have you noticed that people
scream inclusivity when they want to
exclude and respect when they're
disrespecting something and diversity
when they're imposing
uniformity? Here's the latest of the
endless examples of this from the UK.
Dear parents and carers, as we approach
the spring season, I would like to
inform you about an important update
regarding our school's traditional
Easter
celebrations. So, the school has a
tradition. Got to love
traditions. After careful consideration
and discussions with our school
community, we have decided not to hold
the Easter Bonnet Parade or the Easter
service this year. This decision has
been made in the spirit of inclusivity
and respect for the diverse religious
beliefs represented within our school
community. There you have it.
Inclusivity, respect, diverse, the big
three. Watch how many times you see
inclusivity, respect, and diversity in
this letter announcing that the school's
tradition is being excluded because
there's no respect for the tradition
that was already in place and because
local traditions need to be wiped out to
clear a path for a new uniformity.
Our school is committed to fostering an
environment where every child feels
valued and
respected regardless of their religious
background. By not holding specific
religious celebrations, we aim to create
a more inclusive atmosphere that honors
and respects the beliefs of all our
children and their families. We
understand that this change may be
disappointing for some, especially those
who have cherished these traditions over
the years. However, we believe that this
decision aligns with our values of
inclusivity and respect for
diversity. Laying it on pretty thick,
aren't you?
We are exploring alternative ways to
celebrate the season in future years
that will be inclusive of all children
and reflect the rich cultural diversity
of our community. One of the ways we
will be celebrating inclusivity is by
taking part in refugee week which occurs
in June as well as beginning our journey
to become an accredited school of
sanctuary. Sanctuary for refugees. Watch
this space. In the meantime, we look
forward to seeing many of you at the
music festival in a couple of
weeks. Music festival. Music festival.
Music is haram in Islam, you bigots.
What's next? A pork and beer festival?
Bunch of Islamophobes. By the way, wait
until someone complains that the music
festival is offensive. Cancelled. It'll
be replaced by a new tradition of having
all kids of all backgrounds attend
prayers at the local mosque for the sake
of
inclusivity. We appreciate your
understanding and support as we make
this transition. If you have any
questions or concerns, please do not
hesitate to contact the school office.
Thank you for your continued support.
Kind regards, Miss Mander head.
Wow, I'm blown away by all the
inclusivity, respect, and diversity. It
reminds me of a similar story from just
a few months ago. Parents fury after
school tries to ban Christmas references
from its festive pantoime so it can be
inclusive for children of all
faiths. Is it just me or are British
people easily controlled by words? This
happens everywhere, but it seems like a
much bigger problem in Great Britain.
Gangs of men were allowed to horribly
abuse tens of thousands of young British
girls for decades. And the entire
population was kept silent with a couple
of words, Islamophobe and
racist. Any tradition in Great Britain
can be wiped out overnight with a word,
inclusivity or diversity or respect. And
those same words can be used to replace
the tradition with something like
Ramadan. Why can't we have Christmas or
Easter? Because we have to be
inclusive. Oh, okay. So, why do we all
need to celebrate Ramadan? Because we
have to be
inclusive.
Oh, and British people just fall for
this instantly.
Orwell pointed out the problem, but
instead of paying attention and
recognizing their weakness and guarding
their minds and their traditions, the
people of Great Britain decided it's
just time to fade away. We keep thinking
that this is something that's going to
pass, but it's time to be realistic
here. If your culture has become so
incredibly weak and pathetic that it can
be wiped out with a few words, I'd say
your culture is coming to an end.
Do you know what the fall of Great
Britain reminds me
of? My mother and one of my brothers
died of drug
overdoses. Family members get addicted
to drugs and you try to help them.
Sometimes you even help them get totally
clean, but they just keep going back to
the thing that's destroying them. And in
the end, you just can't do enough to
save them.
For me, watching Great Britain destroy
itself is like watching my mom destroy
herself, knowing that no matter how hard
I try, I can't stop
her. You've still got a chance to go to
rehab, people of Great Britain. But you
are rapidly running out of time. If you
keep shoving the needle in your arm,
ooh, I'm being inclusive. Ooh, I'm not
an Islamophobe.
Other nations will mourn for you after
you pass, and you will be missed. And if
it's any consolation, future generations
in other countries will use you as an
example of how a once great nation can
be destroyed by fear of
words. What can the rest of us do? We
can still try to help Great Britain.
Things can always change, but we should
be focusing more on things that last and
on supporting people and countries that
aren't hellbent on
self-destruction. Some people in some
places guard their traditions. They
value them. They cherish them. They're
not ashamed of them. They fight for
them. They understand that if even one
generation gives up, something important
will be lost. They dedicate their lives
to preserving their values, their
traditions, their culture. They can't be
manipulated into destroying themselves
by the latest
buzzwords. And that's why their values
and their traditions and their culture
remain. They don't fade away.
I've been promoting Artza for the past
few months because I really like what
they do, especially when I see entire
nations doing the opposite. Artza
gathers products from local artisans in
Jerusalem and Nazareth and Bethlehem and
other locations and ships them to you in
a box. Every box you buy supports small
local businesses and charities.
businesses and charities run by
Christians and Jews who want to preserve
and celebrate and share their
traditions, not hide them in the name of
exclusion masquerading as inclusion. If
you haven't signed up to receive your
quarterly arts box, the link is in the
description. Use the promo code dizzle
to get a discount.
see the difference between people who
love and share their traditions and
those who have been taught to despise
and hide their own
traditions. Which traditions do you
think will last? Those that are loved
and
shared or those that are despised and
hidden
[Music]